as you can imagine she was quite
apprehensive wasn't sure what to expect
so she went in for questioning and there
was a long discussion there were some
scare tactics used from what i can
gather what were they well about her
family and threats to her family but she
wasn't quite sure what they were getting
at until they gave her her passport her
british passport and bear in mind case
she hasn't seen her british passport
since the 3rd of april 2016 six years
ago so she was astonished to receive her
british passport but when she was
leaving they said don't book a flight
we'll sort out your travel arrangements
essentially
so she left she's now back at home at
her parents house under house rest where
she's been for the last few years she
left even prison because of covert if
you remember and then stayed in the
parents house initially she was wearing
an ankle tag which meant she couldn't go
anywhere outside the house i think she
could walk down one street and that was
it that eventually came off because she
served her five years then she had a one
year sentence and a travel ban she's
currently on her travel ban but the fact
that they've given her british passport
back means that there is some light at
the end of the tunnel
what can we read from the fact that a
british team are in
iran negotiating
i think they wouldn't be in tehran
negotiating if there hadn't been some
movement on the 400 million pound debt
which is what nazanin's case has always
been tangled up in i mean richard
radcliffe as you know because you've
interviewed him before has always
maintained that his wife is a pawn
caught between the two countries british
government disagree of course they do
disagree but nazanin was told herself by
one of the iranian revolutionary guards
when she was in prison that the reason
she was being held is because of our
failure to pay the debt
i don't think there would be a british
negotiating team in tehran if there
hadn't been some movement on the debt i
did ask the foreign office and they said
they couldn't disclose the information
at the moment so she was given a
passport she went back home then what
happened so she's now anxiously waiting
i have been in touch with her and i have
i haven't spoken to open in touch with
her on message like on whatsapp and she
said she's anxiously waiting all she
does when i speak to her is talk about
her daughter because she says she's
missed out on her childhood she's talked
constantly about the fact that she wants
to have another child but what she is
waiting for at this very moment is a
knock on the door to say we are getting
you out of the country
in the past prisoners have gone to a
third country so they've essentially
handed over prisoners to for example
oman or another country that's happened
in the past with prisoners and i think
they're wondering if that will happen to
naznen so it won't necessarily be the
british government that organises
foreign to come home
i think the british government will play
a very big part and i have to say
i've now dealt with five foreign
secretaries and liz trust did say
being a labour mp i can say liz trust
did say from day one when i met her that
it was a number one priority to pay this
debt and bring nazanin home and it
sounds like she has done a good job so
far although
we can finally congratulate her when
nazanin is back on british soil in west
hampstead in her house but we don't know
that the debt has been paid yet and we
also don't know in what form that debt
will be paid because of course because
of sanctions they're not allowed to
receive
money from the uk well it's not it's a
bit more complex than that but they have
they have said to us before that they
would accept um humanitarian aid or
vaccines was mentioned during the height
of the pandemic you're absolutely right
to say we don't know for sure that the
400 million pounds has been paid we
don't know in what form it will be paid
but like i said i do feel like they
probably was some movement because of
the fact that they gave a british
passport back they've had a british
negotiating team in tehran and it seems
like there's some sort of movement
you're speaking to her all the time
how's she filling her days
the same way that she
says she's been filling them all the
time reading the news all the time and
in fact the front pages of all the
iranian newspapers today said that she
had been released and was going home so
you can imagine everyone's been calling
her saying are you going home and she's
just saying well i don't know yet but i
have got my passport in my hands but the
front pages of all the uranium
newspapers she said to me say that
essentially she's no longer a prisoner
she's free to return after six years and
she doesn't know
the national guard didn't tell her when
she might be able to um head home all
they said to her is please don't they
didn't say please i think they just said
and don't book a flight yourself we will
arrange that for you or that will be
arranged for you so um that's all i mean
she did ask she did ask because she
would ask but she didn't get any
clarification on how she would come back
to the uk
but it was very much implied that she
would be able to leave before the end of
the week or
i mean i wish i could say that but i i
don't know for sure and i'm just hoping
it moves and it's also raining new year
banks yeah i think she's had her bags
packed for six years okay she's just
been desperate to leave desperate to get
back home so i think she's anxiously
waiting every time she messages me she
just says
the levels of stress in my life are
quite high and and i think well that's i
think that's fair i think it's fair for
her to say that having a mental health
challenges of course hasn't she she's
been very very low at times when she's
been in prison she's been suicidal she's
had her mental health challenges she was
in isolation she was in solitary
confinement right at the beginning and
she said she was driven to despair at
that point she was suicidal as you say
she has had her mental health challenges
also physical health challenges she had
lumps on her breast she was denied a
medical examination which she finally
got
i would say though one of the things
that did accelerate this process is that
initially nazling was caught up as
collateral damage in the iranian nuclear
deal which then fell apart and when it
did richard radcliffe's lawyers wrote a
very stern and aggressive letter to the
government saying well what's plan b how
are you going to get nazdin out now
because it feels like the nuclear deal
isn't happening so what's the other plan
so i think that's one of the things that
seemed to move it forward and also um
the fact that richard went on hunger
strike and wasn't taking it anymore i
mean the last hunger strike out in the
cold was desperate to watch and um i
think it really demonstrates how
relentless he's been in the campaign for
his wife how is he
he's the calmest man i know is what i
would say to you
when i met him many fault storms before
he has he has and he knows he has to
manage his expectations i mean he can't
start celebrating already but he said to
me that he feels more hopeful this time
than he has in the past i saw him
yesterday we talked through a lot of the
strategy in trouble are you doing still
in the uk he's still in my constituency
so we just met up and had a conversation
and when i left our meeting i said
richard i hope this is the last strategy
meeting we have to have and he just
smiled he didn't you know what can we
say that's what we're hoping but we
don't know for sure and what about the
little one she's a lot bigger than that
now isn't she uh definitely so she knows
she does um she actually we did a panel
at the lsc not long ago richard and i
did she actually came along and she was
chipping into the conversation as well
and it's astonishing to think their
seven-year-old girl knows everything
about the politics in the iranian regime
the iranian revolutionary gods what
prison's like i mean she's lived through
a lot this young girl and so one of the
reasons why i've been campaigning so
much is because
at the heart of this whole political
situation is a very sad
story about a young
girl who's essentially grown up without
both her parents she has that's true
what about um
family who are still in iraq is she
concerned when she does finally leave
about what's going to happen with them
are they coming to
they're not coming as well um her
parents are there and she does have
family there as well
i think nazi's been very compliant in
terms of everything they've said to her
so they said you know don't try and
escape she obviously didn't when they
gave her passport they said don't book a
flight don't do this when she had the
ankle tag she wasn't allowed to go very
far she didn't break the rules she's
actually been very compliant and one of
the reasons for that is because they
keep saying we are going to um they
don't say harm your family this will
affect your family if you break the
rules she was told when she was on
furlough the very first furlough she had
i don't know if you remember a year into
her prison sentence that if she went
anywhere near the british embassy then
horm would come to her family so she's
always been very conscious about the
fact that she has family and friends
there she's got to protect them she
needs to look after them so i think
she's actually been and very good in
terms of following the rules but when
she comes back to the uk she's coming on
her own
and the other two dual nationals do we
know anything about them
um anushia shari is still in prison and
i have heard that he's been moved to
another part of the of the prison that
he's in but not to his mother's house
and
interestingly morad who's the third one
is being treated as an american citizen
by the iranians even though he's jew
national and he did actually live in my
constituency when he lived in england at
the time of his arrest he was in america
which is why he's being treated as an
american citizen so in all the
conversations about this it feels like
anushi ashari is being mentioned and
nazanin is being mentioned i haven't
heard that much about murad and i think
that is because he's being treated as an
american citizen i have raised his case
with the foreign secretary as well
and you know all i can hope for is that
all of them come back
okay well as do we i know you're
speaking to richard every 15 minutes at
the moment aren't you do tell him that
we're thinking about him and gabriella
as well and we hope that they're all
reunited before too long and thank you
kay because you've been supporting us
right from the start in this campaign so
thank you not at all we are here if we
can do anything it's not my looks as
heading in the right direction if
there's anything else we can do just
lift the phone thanks very much indeed
for joining us we really appreciate it
thank you